as we said will show you Attorney
General Reno's news conference in just a
moment the Attorney General was asked
about this video released Thursday by
the FBI which was taken by surveillance
aircraft on April 19 1993 above the
Branch Davidian complex in Waco Texas
the radio traffic you're about to hear
reflects the request for and approval of
the use of military rounds to attempt to
penetrate an underground bunker near the
compound
resupplying probably watch the relative
safety
I utilized the vehicle for solver
again this is 1993 surveillance video
released yesterday by the FBI the voices
you heard were those of FBI hostage
rescue team agents during events in Waco
Texas in April 1993 in just a moment
we'll show you today's news conference
by Attorney General Janet Reno at which
she comments on the video release and
additional new evidence recently
discovered then we'll take you back to a
1993 House Judiciary Committee hearing
nine days after the Branch Davidian
incident at which the Attorney General
and then FBI director William sessions
testified tomorrow at noon Eastern will
re-air portions of 1995 Waco hearings
with testimony from FBI agents and
officials that will continue in our
overnight schedule Saturday night at
2:00 a.m. and next Tuesday you can see
attorney general Reno's testimony at
those same 1995 weigh coherence now